hey everybody welcome to a brand new
series of planet coaster what you're
looking at right now is my first alpha 3
experiments if you will but it's
something that I've been wanting to do
for a really long time now basically
most of my gameplays so far has been to
just try and figure out how to overcome
the limits of the early alphas
I think alpha 3 has added so much new
stuff like all of these new building
elements scenery pieces water and
foliage that I think it's about a good
time to start building the park of my
dreams more or less and just have a lot
of fun with that I'll talk a bit more
about what I'm going to do in the
time-lapse so let's get into it right
now a small disclaimer before we really
get into this video the first two videos
of this series are just going to be
about the entrance Plaza and not the
actual theme park itself I was hoping to
do the entrance in one video but it
turned out to be quite a time-consuming
thing and it became a bit larger than I
was hoping for maybe so we're doing this
in - in this video I'm going to be
making most of the entrance building
itself and in the next video I'll finish
it off and make that Plaza and hopefully
that's all going to look cool in the end
because I have no idea yet but um yeah
the first thing that I wanted to do is
make like the big gates which you're
going to walk underneath to get into the
park and I'll talk a bit more about that
later on but first a bit of an
introduction to this pipe because I'm
pretty sure that it all sounds really
chaotic right now and so yeah for a long
time I was having like some ideas that I
wanted to do in alpha 3 but then I
really wanted to see an alpha 3 which
one would work best what idea was to
make a park like Universal or Disney
just a very large focused on realism
kind of park with this very geometric
sort of layout to it with like one big
centerpiece in the middle of it like a
castle or a lake and the other idea was
to go way less realistic I just throw
realism out of the window basically and
make like a really big sort of fantasy
park with big castles and temples and
everything and just make everything as
large and unrealistic as
possible and trying some stuff in alpha
three I couldn't really decide which one
I wanted to do and then I had the idea
that well I might as well just do both
in a way because the idea behind this
Park is a little bit odd but it's still
somewhat realistic but it will have a
bit of a fantasy theme to it it's
inspired by the happy valley parks in
China which are really relatively
unknown parks in the rest of the world
and there's not a lot of information to
be found of them but China has had a bit
of a theme park boom in recent years and
there's a lot of awesome concept stuff
and images of those parks out there and
what I like about it and why it sort of
hits the - kind of parks that I wanted
to do at first is that it is kind of
very Disney like it does have that
really straight to the well divided
layouts to the park and how it even has
those like big entrances and Main
streets and big sort of structures in
the middle of the park but at the same
time it's a bit more fantasy ish it has
way larger rollercoasters then there's
nips I also want to get into some way
bigger roller coasters as well and just
overall I think it's like some nice
balance between the two kind of hikes
and it's a really good excuse to just go
wild with all of the new scenery pieces
just because many of the parks that I've
made so far in planet coaster sort of
are all according to some sort of
presets theme be it just a country or
steampunk or an elven theme that's sort
of based on reference things this park
is going to be more of its own kind of
style it's more fantasy which sort of
gives it a bit of a wild-card to just do
whatever looks cool and go for some
crazy ideas that I wouldn't want to go
for otherwise if I had to listen to some
sort of realistic theme which is really
cool because you can just go wild with
all of the new pieces and that's just a
lot of fun because most of all the
reason why I wanted to do this kind of
park this is because I think it's a lot
of fun and I am very well aware that
I've already done this sort of thing in
rollerCoaster Tycoon 3 before and
if you're a very longtime viewer you
might remember some of the earlier
quakes which do have a bit of a similar
style and idea to it as the Main Street
and the entrance plaster which I'm going
to be doing here so it's not all that
new but it's just something that I've
been wanting to try in planet coaster
for a really long time and yeah alpha 3
is just a really good opportunity to do
so so let's get back to the building for
a little bit this building is already
quite a fantasy like building I'm not
really sure what kind of style I would
really say it is and I don't really know
too much about it anyway but it's a bit
gothic I think actually slightly
inspired by some of the English
buildings it does have a very English
Victorian sort of look to it kind of
like the Big Ben or Manchester City Hall
that kind of idea with the towers but I
also wanted to have this very large
gates in the middle of it which is
inspired by concept arts of a Happy
Valley theme park that doesn't exist at
least not yet but it was that idea of
having this large arch as you come into
the park kind of like you have in
Universal as well and on the side there
I need to get those smaller arches in
because obviously this very large arch
is not enough for the entrance and exits
of a large park like this so most of the
entry stuff is going to be happening
underneath those arches on the side of
this building now what this building
most of all does is really sort of give
you that sort of greeting into the park
it's a pretty recognizable building
hopefully and even though I will have
all sorts of buildings on the side of it
they're going to be kind of it's smaller
and less unique in a sense so this will
really bit up that landmark as you
approach the park that sort of first
impression is important right so this is
going to be the hopefully good first
impression as you walk into the park
it's all going to be a little bit
symmetrical it's obviously not the same
on both sides
but it's that idea of having this
symmetrical path layouts with a very
large wide plaza in front of it and
facades on all sides to sort of give you
an idea of what the park is going to
look like
get that grande entrance in but at the
same time of course getting some
necessary for things in on the sides
like toilets or whatever else I want to
have information around the side of the
entrance that sort of thing
so the basic entrance building is done
and so is the path work and the rest
that I'll be doing in this video is
working on the facades on the side of
this to make those big wings of
buildings that kind of greet you as you
go on to the entrance Plaza and they'll
all be buildings with slightly different
styles as you might have seen in that
little teaser at the beginning of the
video but this entire area is going to
have a very fantasy European touch to it
I did say that this would be a fantasy
like Park so I'm not strictly listening
to any styles here which just makes
everything a bit easier and more fun but
I will be having different themed areas
and like one big centerpiece for the
park and the different kind of areas
that I want to get into are like a
European fantasy we've also got an Asian
setting definitely America is going to
happen though it's probably going to be
mostly South America and getting into
temples and that kind of stuff and also
Africa and all of those themes will be
quite fantasy so I don't really have to
listen to any like real life sort of
rules to all of the architecture that I
don't really know much about but um yeah
it's going to be a lot of fun basically
and it's a kind of idea which I've been
wanting to try for a long time now the
European setting will be like the
central part of the park and I'm trying
not to be too biased here not because
I'm European but just because I think it
works out best I would have said Europe
is on the middle of the earth map so
that kind of makes sense but it really
doesn't I'm pretty sure that every
continent likes to put themselves in the
middle of the map but yeah we'll have
Europe in the middle just because I
think it works out best for the theme
and I had this idea for like the big
entrance Plaza and the main street being
European so that will be European for
sure and the same goes for like the big
weenie that I'll have at the end of the
Main Street which I am very sorry it is
most likely going to be a castle which I
know it's the millionth Castle which
I've built already
but um it's the first time in alpha
three and with all of these new pieces
and I think that's the one thing that I
really really want to try plus I think
you promised somebody that I would make
a castle so I don't think I can get out
of that one so that's the thing that
I'll be doing and then around that we'll
have the different themed areas very
much like a Disney park but also very
much like Happy Valley so yeah that's
basically how things are going to be
done and as for the Europeans a section
it's all going to be like slightly
inspired by different things so I get
some buildings that are like a little
bit more English and some that are a bit
more Alpine ish and just got like a
general sort of style with the spires
and the colors and the textures of the
buildings that all sort of bring them
together and make sure that it doesn't
look too messy but still they have
slightly different styles for the
different building so as you can see
with the second building that I'm doing
here which is the big toilet building
it's a bit more Alpine inspired
especially with that gable that really
comes out of the front and with all of
the all of the woodwork that I'll have
in the wooden windows it's very Alpine
inspired kind of Austrian Bavarian kind
of idea and I think if it's quite nice
actually like right next to the more
English building get some slightly
different looking textures and things in
there while still having some sort of
the same look to it that's the Alpine
building and many of these buildings
will be like not some of your typical
facades at least not in a sense that you
see them in many Disney made streets or
other things like that they are quite
messy buildings in a way they're gonna
be buildings with a lot of like nooks
and crannies and balcony sticking outs
and different parts like normally you
would see many buildings as being one
big flat facade next to another big flat
facade I don't have anything that sticks
out or any smaller towers of balconies
or anything like that but I do want to
make these buildings a bit more dynamic
thematts and have all sorts of stuff
coming out on all the sides just makes
them a bit more fun to look at I think
and also makes them fit in a bit better
with the big arch that is the entrance
of the park
so into the third building which isn't
really inspired by any particular
country but just a way to get some nice
sort of a castle ish stuff into this
section of the park and I really felt
like building this kind of tower so this
is the little castle mention kind of
building with some different colors as
well I didn't really have too many
greens yet and I'm going to recolor the
walls they're still white grayish but I
wasn't too happy with that in the end so
I recall it it to a slightly lighter
brown and this is really one of those
buildings that gives it a bit more of a
like medieval fantasy kind of touch to
the entire plaza and this is probably
the most playful building in a way that
it has like all of these different parts
sticking out the roofs are on different
heights and there's the tower in the
front of it with the tower on the side
as well and that sort of thing which
comes over the side with like that low
wooden supported roof which is going to
come over like the door which I'll have
at some point there underneath it and I
think actually this building probably
would still stand best on its own as
well I think for many of these buildings
I'm going to post them on the workshop
as well they're just going to be the
Front's of the buildings I will put a
big red box behind it just to make sure
that they do look like the sun's on a
otherwise very simple building but with
a few windows and walls and things like
that on the sides and at the back of the
building I think these would work quite
well as objects that you can just open
as blueprints from the workshop and I
think I'll put them on the workshop if I
can if they don't have too many items in
one building so you'll probably see
those pop up sometime soon that's all I
really wanted to say about this building
I think it's time to move on to the next
one and the next one is going to be a
bit more of a simple building I did want
to make sure that all of these buildings
are slightly more simple and less
detailed than like the big entrance so
that's still the building that sticks
out the most but on this side just to
have something a bit different than on
the other side I didn't want to have
Rufe that comes out to the front and I
also didn't want to have a building with
the tower because it felt a bit too
close to the towers of the entrance
building and I do sort of want to build
the buildings up to what the entrance
bit so they'll get a bit higher as you
come closer to the entrance to kind of
give you that feeling that the glass is
larger than it really is so that's
something that I wanted to get in there
and it also kind of just made sure that
the buildings in the front of the plans
that I've really to Wharf the gate which
is placed quite a bit to the back of it
but yeah this is really quite a simple
building now I find that a clockwork
piece which I wasn't really too sure
what you use it for but I did want to
use it in something since it it's a
really beautiful piece so I ended up
going with this building since it's very
simple and sort of changed the color
scheme to match a bit with the colors of
that clock thing and that's basically
everything that this building has going
for it aside from the clock
it's just walls with a roof and windows
which is basically any building but this
one's a bit more simple it also doesn't
really have any function
it's just that fancy thing that sort of
sits right next to the big entrance
gates and I put those same roof pieces
on top of it just to make it fit in a
little bit better but also because I
really love those roof pieces they
really just make any kind of spire
fancier just by putting that let golden
little top piece on top of it which you
can actually use swords for as well but
that's something which I'll get into
later on anyway the very last building
of this entrance Plaza and this is once
again a bit of an importance building it
is the way that it's it's sort of is
setup is that the building in the middle
which is the big entrance is like the
most important thing that so that really
has to come out the most but these there
are going to be two corner buildings on
both sides with one tower at the end to
sort of mark the end of these rows and I
wanted to put quite a bit of work into
these things as well now this building
I'm not really sure if it has any kind
of style I always feel it's
a little bit russian almost in the way
that it's set up and laid out but aside
from that it doesn't really have many
details that would say so at all and not
really sure what exactly the style of
this would be I just thought it would
fit in the way that it is so that's the
way that we're doing it and I was
playing a little bit with the details on
this building I more yeah more or less
taken the details of the game for what
they are in the other buildings but in
this one I kind of wanted to see like
how you can really combine the different
pieces to make new stuff and I'm
actually test for a while what height of
tower I wanted to have as well so most
of the borders on this building and
especially on the top piece here on the
top of the tower are like combinations
of different items and taking those
swords and actually putting them on top
of the roof works quite well to get that
sort of goal and spire look to it and
the bottom of this flag is actually
quite used for the useful for that kind
of thing as well like it's a big golden
sort of pointy spire top that you would
see it's definitely something which I
have kind of missed in the game for
quite a while and I guess I'm trying to
make up with for that by placing perhaps
too many of them but this is just the
way that I kind of wanted to try it out
here now aside from the tower and how
much I kind of wanted to play with the
details like the rims there were there
trims I should say and the sides of the
building
I didn't really play much with any of
the windows or anything like that just
because I do like detailing stuff which
I guess some infamous for at this points
but I definitely want to keep it a bit
spread out at some points and make sure
that certain parts of buildings owned as
detailed and since I went well into lot
of detail on those like the foundation
and on the top parts of this building I
wanted to keep the walls quite empty and
not add too much to those just so that
the details at least come out of it and
the entire building doesn't just become
one big sugar-coated pie
basically and another habit that I go to
was placing a lot of wood on this
building especially around the
decorations which for the kind of
building that is not sure how much sense
it makes but it's
just it's that kind of thing where the
very yellow very light colors didn't pop
out a lot from the very light and white
gray ish bricks of the building so all
of those wooden planks is kind of helped
get us some slightly darker colors into
the details which kind of accent them a
bit I think so that works out quite well
they're the same also kind of works with
the pillars on the side of the building
so this is what it looks like as a
finished building or almost finished I
guess I could say because most of these
buildings are still missing some of the
smaller details in front of it like
hanging baskets and some lanterns and
like little scenery items on the ground
I'll definitely get into that in the
next episode but um aside from that this
is more or less adding the final touches
to the building so that's it for today
thank you guys so much for watching and
I hope to see you guys in the next video
in which I'll finish off this blazer so
we can finally head into the rest of the
park